okay good evening a and thanks very much
for hanging on for the last presentation
of the evening and my name is brian
carter and i'm currently working as a
data scientist in IBM in dublin and
there's some my contact details all the
i pipe notebooks for this presentation
are up on my github account and for
anyone that wants to download them so
previously to work in IBM i worked for
an unguarded corner and which is the
irish police force and this presentation
is kind of an offshoot of a project that
I worked on there but i suppose and it's
kind of when i was learning python the
aim i found and then when people put
projects up on github with the i pipe
notebooks and it was really good way of
learners and so it's a step true of
hated to a web scrape em and then
analysis and i was delighted when the
last presenter introduced the topic of
drugs and because the web scrape and
focuses in on and a website called pill
reports dotnet and a this is an online
database m of reviews of ecstasy pills
and I suppose M when you when you think
about drugs in consumer theory their
experience okay a better okay and so in
when you think about drugs in a consumer
theory their experience God's so in
terms of you don't actually know what
you've bought onto the time of
consumption and and very like other
review sites and for restaurants or
hotels they can viewed as a bridge
between that knowledge gap in terms of
people trying to investigate and find
out and what they are buying before they
buy it and the most some of the
motivation behind this was was it
possible to identify mr2 and where an
identifiable pill is producing
undesirable and
faqs so I just conversion here so so
this is an example of a typical em
review on pill reports net and this is m
called an orange done pairing young
ecstasy pill and so there's lots of
different fields associations in terms
of and the days of submitted where the
report came from some information about
the logo honest aim at the size and then
typically the way people are interacting
with the website is that they are am
putting in a description of the hill and
then there's two fields down the bottom
where it's related to consumed and
warning and that's where it has somebody
actually and consumed the pill and then
when they consume he'll they'll
typically write a report about the
effects that they have and when the
people are putting up a reviews where
they haven't consumed the pill they're
typically looking for other people to a
in the comments section 2 m start and
giving them information about like and
the M the effects of the pill so in this
case and somebody says that reaction
looks weird or something else is saying
hey I've taken these pills before and
they're great and so here's an example
of it's called yellow Instagram and
he'll and so they've provided a picture
of us and then the guy has provided like
a report of like am after he's taken the
pill how it's the effects that he's
feeling so like me at one stage he says
okay this I'm starting to get really
high and I feel like touch my face and
all this kind of stuff and so this loads
really interested in information in m in
the data so the outline of what I'm
going to go true and it's kind of a fun
presentation so it's not an overly
technical i'm going to go true how I
scraped the data a little bit about the
cleaning and some experience is doing
Josh exploration and and then a little I
am is sort of some of the insights that
n you get I got out of the data and I am
that are quite quite interesting so I'm
using the euro air lib to and package to
connect to the web page parsing which
beautiful soup and if this tree and
pages are three HTML page the data in it
so when I'm connecting or when I'm going
into each ma report I'm just checking if
there are three tables and if it's if I
can on it so if not I'm just rejecting
the web page and it's it's if the pill
reports is quite a simple websites but
it's not there's not much dine at
there's no dynamic content on it
sometimes reports are pulled down by
administrators because somebody puts in
and identify the details in terms of
maybe the nightclub they were rain or a
name of a person or something like that
so then once the data is scraped I set
up an a database in a MongoDB and M and
just in the former's because sometimes
when you're playing around to this kind
of stuff em it kind of might do a couple
of scrapes until you get to the point
where you're getting working so the
database is set up with the name of
today's date and then if M every time I
hits and the MongoDB if the database
exists am I just dropped the dash space
and Recreation again and the so and and
then it's very straightforward in terms
of the tables and on the first column
have and the the categories out the
column headings and so I'm just reading
that into a Python dictionary and using
the first column is the keys and the
second columns are the values I do some
basic cleaning out that stage in terms
removing white spaces and any extra HTML
tags and then insert in the dictionary
into
a collection in there as the document
enter and one of the collections in the
[ __ ] DB so there's two collections in
the MongoDB one for the reports and one
for the action comments associated with
it and that actually works really well
it's very straight forward to the
dictionary mastery and pie [ __ ] and
just a flies at that same and it's
really nice very handy way of doing that
and collecting the information so I'm
not going to go into too much m of the
cleaning of the data it's all the usual
stuff in terms of renaming and columns
cleaning up your day formats and some
geocoding and because the the cities and
towns are quite dirty I'm quite messy
and creating some integers and then and
categorize as much mulch normal isn't
that kind of stuff and one thing I did
him to am so sorry that's just an
connected sin monk with DB and then
reading the collection into the pandas
dash brain and that actually works Brit
them they're really really fast m4 for
doing that so and so once you have it in
the pan to start frame a from fly away
that so one that library did use em was
lang detect and that's a heightened port
of a google and library for language
detection and its aim a naive Bayes rule
sesh and it can detect and 49 languages
with 99 percent accuracy having a bed 10
to 12 words and depending on the
language and I suppose I'm a native
English speaker and so when the reports
can be in lots of different languages so
for for doing the analysis I later on I
want to filter and by just those reports
that are written in English so that's
kind of a breakdown of em sort of where
and the the reports are coming from say
the top seven so the top country is the
US m and its top language is English as
well and with [ __ ] three of the five
thousand reports and I did this on em I
to the the language detection on the
user reports field sometimes that's not
filled out depending on whether somebody
has consumed
the pianist and so the the u.s. is the
biggest air country Ireland's not doing
too bad per capita in terms of the
number of reports that it's a submission
no really so one of the things I'm so I
work em with a lot of different tools
when I am and I'm doing data mining and
one of the things and I suppose that M
is it was a steep learning curve for me
is doing visualization in tighten em so
I kind of played around with large
libraries I was really interested
yesterday to hear and the different
developments in the area of
visualization with bulky and and other
stuff and so my experience in using
their pipe in visualization it takes a
bit longer to get to the point where you
want to visualize and typically am for
most of the library's you have to do the
aggregation and the role of em outside
and before you feed it into that into
them into bed the plot that you want to
create whereas I suppose when you look
at some of the libraries like in or like
ggplot in GG vis a lot of that M is is
sort of embedded in the API a.m. and you
can get to that point with a lot less
cold and a lot quicker and so this is
just one am sort of insight in terms of
the number of reports that have been
submitted to the website over the
two-year period so you can see the
downward trend in the number of reports
and so following on from that then
another thing I wanted to kind of look
at is it what's the breakdown between
the number of reports for a warning and
is where somebody says that yet this
pill is ok so there's no warning and
attached to us and somebody says yes I
had a bad experience when I took this
pill and again it's sort of this M if M
sort of it as an example in terms of
trying to create em are getting to
create a simple stack plus and you kind
of have to go through a few jumps to get
to the point where you want to
you're like the percentages and that
kind of stuff in terms of creating
arrays and all the kinds of and I
suppose again the insight here is that
over the time period the number of em
reports that have a warning equal to yes
is shrinking and so that's kind of an
interesting and insights to find in the
data and thus that's going on so then
the classification em so the first
m-model our M is from what I've shown
here is it's just a very simple naive
Bayes model and using the description
field as in the free text and field
creating the vector representation and
then using the warning label as the
target label and and so I'm I'm
filtering the rows and to where the
language is English and that's the
distribution and it doesn't change in
terms of so there's about it I've the
labels wrong there should be am
sixty-five percent of all reports or no
and thirty-five percent of all reports
or yes so that's the the setup for am
creating the vectorization and am
creating the model and I've used the
pre-processing laboring ill encoder and
for the warning label to create that
into numeric value and cross validation
for the Train test pipeline which is
really nice and in terms of if you want
to try lots of different things and you
can wrap em your pipeline in a loop and
pick out and your different models you
want to em em from a list and feed them
in you get a nice result and also the
pipeline allows for an and for all your
pre-processing steps and so you can
repeat them then when you're doing that
on the test data and as well and then
printing out the train scores and using
the the metrics and feature so that's
just a first pass and which am using all
the features you get in the train and
acts three of 73
in 72 then for the test score so then
one of the things like em that kind of
you often try and do then is ok kind of
rich reduced and the features and and
and so in cyclic learn currently and one
of the implementations of feature
waiting or at the very are the
calculation the variable of them for
importance is the choice square value so
again that's an some of the the code
associations em which do not aim and
it's fairly straightforward I am using a
use the Ezra tools and compress and here
too so I'm selecting the top 250
features based on their choice score and
and then a filtering out my features
based on these am using it and the user
tools compress and and then calculating
an a data frame and tick and to account
over the words counts placed by the
warning label so for a particular word
that ha m is the highest and choice
square score and how many em for a
binary occurrence how many documents
doesn't occur in for the warning label
equal to yes in the morning label equal
to no and so that's just an a print i ra
the breakdance so the word black am
having the highest high score and it's
in for a documents and where the warning
label is no sin 203 and for yes in 27
and it's sort of one of the interesting
things then I kind of it was like going
ok what if I visualize this information
and to see what I am what that looks
like and so I just feed that into a map
plot lay there and scatter plot and and
I hope you can see this
no I'm I got any bigger so what you can
see is M between the yes is on the y
axis and the no on the x axis you can
see the separation between the two
classes m and the the points are and
sized by their choice score the relative
high school and then I also call her to
the points by and stop words so
sometimes when you're doing an analysis
using text and you can further there is
a set of english stuff words answer you
filter them out and then you go okay my
models gotten worse sir and at that kind
of stuff and so a lot of the stuff words
mrm have a high score and that's because
they feature in phrases and in terms of
so a phrase associated with em a warning
equal to guess is stay away and a way is
an english in the given set em of stop
words in the NL TK package and a way is
one of the staff boards so it's kind of
a thing like to to sort of be conscious
of in terms of when you when you do a
filter out words and head I can impact
and then of course you can create like
by grants as well like me to to a to
combat that up but then you increase
your feature session as well so this is
just a zoomed-in plus m of the same
information and what's interesting here
is that you start to get an insight into
and it's some of the M in terms of like
to make if the domain knowledge and
insights into what's going on there and
it's probably very hard to see here but
some of the words that are associated
with the M
a warning equal to yes it's still for
both and taste and sarah m and and
different suffer around that and in
terms of em ecstasy production and the
the current model is in terms of a ma
sort of in a global level is prohibition
and so as part of that a lot of
countries have em prohibited some of the
chemicals that you use to make ecstasy
and one of them being saffron and a very
similar m-type chemical that you can use
em is anise seed oil and which goes into
the manufacturer of MDMA but actually
produces a different drug called pmma
which has similar effects as ecstasy but
m is more toxic and works in a different
way and so when that's kind of em so and
the resulting pills do have a sour taste
and so you're seeing that information
and being bubbled up there in the users
equal to or when people are and have a
report and they're saying they actually
is a warning or they've had a bad effect
and with those pills so then another
kind of interesting of fun thing I've
and Slyke ever said to do is like look
at the user report fields and that's
where somebody has consumed a pill and
see is there any kind of nice
interesting stuff touch em we can add
that can look us in that aspect and and
so I've just i filtered them the rose to
where the language is english and just
some of the top countries in terms of em
and given in reports and I want to see
as well maybe it's the difference in the
type of language that people used in
different countries a and then so the
way I kind of went Barras was to look at
creating are created a binary vector
representation of stemmed words and
normalizes and then at 378 features and
then did PR performed PCA with em and
the first two components PCA explain
about three and a half percent of the
variance
and so one of the things in a PC are
currently in psychic lair and I'm not
sure it might have changed since I've
done this is that M the the sparse
matrix representation you can't actually
do at PCA in cyclic learn so you have to
M convert your sparse matrix into am a
regular matrix and when you're doing
that so and then basically em a I do
this all the time is a greatness scatter
plot of the components and then
overlaying at the nominal values and see
like is there any interesting patterns
in that so this is a bit like a skittles
church m so this is M it's the same plot
over and over again m written it are
done matplotlib and then overlaying
different and different nominal
variables so the first one is and just a
k-means clusters with three clusters in
am I didn't really investigate in terms
of what those clusters are the second m1
over to the right is and the points are
colored by the length of the of the
documents that's gone into it so you can
kind of sort of em make the the the
arguments that the the first principal
component is capturing some of the
information or length related to the
length of the documents this chart here
and Hayes and the points are colored by
the weather the warning label is no or
yes you can see there is good separation
between the two and classes there the
next one over is looking at the
suspected contents so in terms of
whether somebody believes that they have
am taken a pill that contains MDMA or
it's an unknown or they've taken
something that they believe has a I'm
fetch mean or pippers eens and all that
kind of stuff so you can see there is
kind of a sort of very visual person
there that you can see that MDMA is more
associated with their the red points
here on the Left which are and the
labels equal to where the warning is
equal to know and I'm buying some stuff
um it's very hard to see on this screen
in terms of and curling the points then
by the country of origin and
it and there's some so you can see some
separation there and I'll not and then
bye week day as well it's not really
much enough so then the sort of the last
thing that I suppose when and you're
looking at text data and is and you have
to do your bleak ettore workload and so
this is just pulling out the reviews
from the F in the user report field and
applying NLT k for the word tags and
then I just sort of said that adjectives
and nouns are rich words and then
plotting up our dune using a a word
cloud package that was developed by a
guy called andreas Mueller and then just
like literally him art and surfacing up
the workout which is just like the word
came I'm splitting it up by whether the
person believe that their suspected
contents were MDMA and fat means are
unknown it's kind of interesting because
you kind of get the some of the
information which somebody takes MDMA
they're using words and like em love and
euphoric and and then some of the
physical stuff in terms of like their
eyes rolling and when people are have
taken out what they believe to be on
fish means the words are used nor much
more surrounded belly and rush and sleep
on awake and that kind of stuff and then
the people and who have taken pills but
they don't know what they've taken you
get a much more focus in on say the
negative physical effects in terms of
feeling sick and the taste em or weird
sure is unsure am and that kind of stuff
so that's my presentation I hope you
find it interesting and if you've any
questions or comments please
hi very interesting presentation my
question would be were you able to make
any suggestions about the the provenance
of these drugs based on that if you if
you look at these you say certain words
occur so I guess at the end of the day
you've got different groups of the pills
and we're using these groups are able to
say you know these five percenter may be
coming from a certain supplier or these
Tim person from another one and what
kind of siskel methods or what was your
methodology for doing that and did that
have any impact on investigations or
anything like that yeah I suppose like
in terms of em when I started the
project I was then and working in the
Irish police force and I subsequently
moved to em jobs and kind of turned into
a more fun and type of project and so it
terms it that there is like I mean I
think this aim in terms of that data set
this is probably a lot of work the
comedian in terms of a categorizing
because the there is branding associated
with em ecstasy pills but they're okay
there's no you don't buy it with the
package on a name sort of thing but
people are putting names up there so
this probably a lot of work that you
could way it can be done in terms of
taking them I didn't do anything with
the images are all that kind of stuff to
see if maybe you can use the image
information to group that and then like
to tidy up like me in terms of what you
believe our groups and that kind of
stuff but i didn't i didn't do any
research into that area there was
another question here hi i didn't quite
pick up from your code examples you you
were using NLT k and sk learn together I
didn't can you say a little bit whether
where you actually like processing data
with NLT k and then pushing it into sk
learn if you work and you say a little
bit how that works because i have worked
with both but i find they use very very
different data structures yeah yeah so
am I in terms of the examples am I sure
AM I wasn't pushing an information from
NL ck in terms of where you're tagging
words or anything like that into
into the SK learn so the only thing that
I was putting into the algorithms is the
matrix of the words of the bag of words
and collectors I didn't do any
processing and with the NLT k to feed
into them into that more questions
anywhere I'm so was it possible to use
other features as predictors for example
size shaped image color yet so so so in
terms of the classification them the cat
what I showed you in the presentation
and was the description in terms of
could you build out their classification
and with the with the text in the
description you get the like seventy two
percent I'm like when you use the user
report when somebody's consumed you can
bump that up to ninety percent but I
suppose the in terms of building knows
they say a sort of a a youth feature may
be on the website and terms frequent
feet are different features when I fed
more and that stuff and it didn't have
any and sort of impact on the phone I
was able to get up start but I think and
in terms of the sort of some of the
motivation for this a.m is that it's a
sort of being used as a learning example
for people start and doun tightened and
scrape know the kind stuff so I didn't
do anything which like creating by grams
and said then trying to see how that
would impact hi quick questions I've
heard a lot about scrapy recently for
web scraping I notice you use your Allah
URL lib to and beautiful soup are you
familiar with scrapie and if so can you
say why you didn't choose it or sort of
compare the product for the legends i
know i'm not familiar vs that's the
financer okay i do not see any other
questions so let's thank the speaker
again and
you
you